China has unveiled more details about a
new national security law being drafted
for Hong Kong it says Beijing will set
up a new national security Bureau in
Hong Kong supervised by the central
government to crack down on dissent in
the city critics fear it will crush
wide-ranging freedoms that are seen as
key to Hong Kong's status as an
autonomous financial centre let's cross
over to correspondents Matias building
here in Beijing and Phoebe Kong in Hong
Kong Matias first with you what are
those details
yeah these details are quite shocking to
those who might have been hoping that
this might be some kind of a milder
version or that a lot of the
jurisdiction might still stay in Hong
Kong so the Hong Kong government will
form as a National Security Agency
chaired by the chief executive and that
National Security Agency this committee
will also appoint the judges that will
handle these cases so this is one very
problematic case from the point of the
rule of law but then China will also
establish its own National Security
Agency and this National Security Agency
will engage in intelligence gathering
but it has also the right to take over
some of the cases a small number as was
said in this communication but nobody of
course knows what this small number is
the these community communication that
was not the text of the draft but it was
a summary of some of the key points of
the draft did not really specify what
will contain a crime these these four
crimes in detail there like sedition
secession they are very they are not
very detailed they're very broad so we
do not really know what will consist as
a crime in the end
okay thanks Matthias let's jump over to
Hong Kong and Phoebe how are people that
are taking this news
while the Swiss of the news are handset
has set shockwaves across the city as
mentioned the the content of the law is
still like very fake at this stage but
this is worrying enough for many
citizens in the Hong Kong especially the
opposition came some of the
pro-democracy figures they are they they
criticize the new legislation is
actually a nightmare for the city that
they they afraid that is it it is going
to hinder the remaining traditional
independence of a city because the
churches will be appointed by the chief
executive which is not democratically
elected in Hong Kong then they they
afraid that the remaining independent
judiciary and the power to check and
violence will fade away under the new
legislation so are people really afraid
and also the new Department of National
Security Asians on there are so many
details that we don't know but the
opposition came they fear that this is
going to be a tool for the regime to
crack down on democracy movement like
photo well what do you think will happen
next then briefly Phoebe will the
democracy movement continue what can we
proceed
well at the moment that have been caused
by a metal online/offline that as people
- I come out to say no to national
security legislation but given the fact
that the government in Hong Kong is
still imposing the social distancing
restriction that they prohibit public
gatherings are over 50 people so it's
really hard for the people or activists
to go on the street right now but we see
the momentum here like people are
definitely very concerned about the new
law so people are finding ways in a more
peaceful and legitimate way to express
their concerns like online signing
statements or a summit unions are now
calling for strike but we're not like
very optimistic that massive match could
take place in the short coming future
okay thank you to you both EB Kong in
Hong Kong and Matthias Berliner in
Beijing for us